it's tuesday january fourteenth and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters back for another day subbing in
for Jess McDonald and have I got
something special for you folks I call
it battlefield 4 players rejoice or at
least get slightly mollified developer
dice has launched a new update for the
pc ps4 and ps3 versions of the game that
addresses stability and balance issues
graphical glitches and repair speeds you
can read the full patch notes on
gamespot in the news section but a few
noteworthy fixes include that bug
whereby friendly markers wouldn't always
show up when you needed them and the bug
which causes player ranked icons on the
scoreboard to not be updated dice has
also added a twenty-five percent
increase in damage for stealth jet
20-millimeter cannons and they've
normalized repair rates across all
vehicles so that the ones with lower
health points like aircraft and
transport vehicles now repair more
slowly than before I imagine a lot of
you will take to the comments and share
your own experiences with battlefield 4
bugs but what I'm actually curious about
is if any of you have applied the patch
and noticed any updates let me know next
we've got an update on the upcoming halo
movie there is no upcoming halo movie
responding to recent internet rumblings
a microsoft representative told GameSpot
today as we've previously stated we have
no plans for a halo motion picture at
this time starting in 2005 when peter
jackson was set to helm the project and
up through last year when Elysium
director neill blomkamp expressed
interest in it a halo movie has been
much rumored but little realized Master
Chief may end up on the silver screen
someday but for now you're just gonna
have to make do with that TV series
Forward Unto Dawn which I actually
thought was pretty not terrible
moving on to our third major FPS
franchise of the day call of duty
co-developer sledgehammer games appears
to be hiring on a bunch of new staff as
they get ready to work on a new Call of
Duty title CVG reported that positions
listed on linkedin include a multiplayer
designer a concept artist and a senior
animator various listings say the team
is working on a quote next gen call of
duty game and indeed Activision has
already confirmed a new call of duty 4
2014 but sledgehammer previously worked
with Infinity Ward and they made ghosts
so this should be treyarch seer to
develop call of duty so is sledgehammer
gonna work with Treyarch or are they
actually working on 2015's call of duty
or is there some information you folks
know that I don't set me straight or
speculate with me in the comments below
evolve the new asymmetrical multiplayer
shooter from the creators of left 4 dead
is coming out this fall for the
PlayStation for the Xbox one and the PC
and wouldn't you know it there's a
pre-order bonus in the form of a Darth
Maul e monster skin and a new monster
character that will be released after
launch if you hadn't heard about this
game yet do yourself a favor and read
about it on our site because it looks
sweet and as a little thank you for
watching today's show I'll leave you
with some footage of this awesome dude
making an awesome replica of sephiroth's
awesome sword from the awesome Final
Fantasy 7 share your thoughts on today's
news by tweeting using the hashtag GS
news or by commenting below and I'll see
you tomorrow
you